historien et spécialiste des états unis
françois durpaire françois durpaire
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors pourquoi cette affaire est devenu
bien plus qu'un fait divers est
bouleversée bouleverse autant dans le
pays parce que c'est pas la première
affaire évidemment la matière vous savez
qu'il ya aux états unis à un mouvement
qui s'appelle le blacklight matin la vie
des noirs comptent et qui dénoncent tous
les actes racistes à l'encontre de la
communauté africaine américaine ce qui
touche plus particulièrement dans cette
affaire c'est à la fois et bien la
tragédie raciste mais c'est aussi le la
lenteur de la justice
il a fallu deux mois pour que l' enquête
avance et finalement sans cette vidéo
prise par un téléphone portable d'une
d'une voiture sans cette vidéo là et
bien probablement que les deux
intéressés
les deux criminels auraient sans doute
pu échapper à la justice
là c'est devenu difficile il ya plus de
300 millions maintenant de témoins
oculaires d'américains même sur la
planète tout le monde maintenant connaît
la sphère est donc évidemment on passe
d'une affaire locale à une affaire qui
est désormais fédérale alors le ministre
de la justice de géorgie a demandé
dimanche qu'une enquête fédérale soit
ouverte sur la manière dont cette
affaire de meurtre a été traité par les
autorités locales alors qu'elles sont
finalement les points à élucider
alors c'est important cette enquête
fédérale parce que ça va déterminer
quelle est la part finalement de
d'intentionnalité raciste dans ce crime
d'abord on sait que la mise en examen ne
s'est fait pas cette sur la base d'un
homicide
mais vraiment sur la base d'un meurtre
qui est une distinction aux états unis
s'agit pas d'un homicide involontaire
c'est important aussi de passer à l'
enquête fédérale parce que aux états
unis et bien il y a évidemment une
justice locale avec des lois locales et
la géorgie c'est particulier c'est
particulier d'abord parce que il y a des
lois en mesure en mal
hier d'autodéfense qui sont extrêmement
permissive
vous avez le droit quand vous êtes
citoyen en géorgie et bien d'interpeller
un autre citoyen parce que vous pensez
qu'il est en train de commettre un délit
et puis il faut aussi rappeler que la
géorgie est l'un des cinq états aux
états unis à ne pas aggraver la peine
d'un criminel pour des raisons racistes
les autres états des 45 états le fonds
alors évidemment pourquoi parce que la
georgie et bien là et d'un état sudiste
un état du sud profond où le racisme est
encore très prégnant mais cette affaire
est en passe de devenir une affaire
nationale en période électorale et vous
savez que donald trump à plusieurs
reprises a été pointé du doigt dans ses
relations à la communauté africaine
américaine d'une part et aux
suprémacistes blancs d'autre part alors
justement un donald trump a déclaré que
la situation était vraiment très
perturbantes comment est-ce qu'on peut
interpréter comprendre ces propos du
président américain
le évidemment l'adjectif choisi est un
adjectif assez assez floue on sait pas
exactement ce qu'il entend par
perturbante il c'est donald trump qu'il
est en période électorale alors la
communauté africaine américaine elles
votent massivement pour les démocrates
il ya fort à parier que ce sera encore
le cas début novembre prochain en
revanche on a beaucoup reproché à donald
trump d'adopter ce qu'on appelle aux
états unis la salle zone stratégique est
ce que ça veut dire la stratégie du sud
c'est une stratégie mise en place par
des présidents républicains notamment
depuis richard nixon et qui consiste à
rester flou en matière d'affaires
raciale pour
obtenir le vote des blancs du sud et on
sait qu'un certain nombre d'états du sud
seront des étapes déterminant en devant
des étapes qu'on appelle aux états unis
vous avez les swing states notamment par
exemple la virginie à voir les blancs du
sud pour un président républicain
pourrait être déterminant pour être
déterminant en novembre prochain et donc
ne pas s'aliéner cette frange de
l'électorat qui reste marqué par cette
histoire de ségrégation raciste
finalement aux états unis les violences
envers les afro-américains à vous
entendre est encore minimiser en tout
cas dans certains états comment est-ce
qu'on peut le comprendre
alors elles sont minimisés pas par tous
les américains
ces veillées lorsque l'on fait des
enquêtes d'opinion c'est une des grandes
divisions de la société américaine
vous avez plus de 90 % des africains
américains qui considèrent que les
violences racistes sont un vrai problème
et vous avez presque la proportion
similaire de blancs américains qui
estiment qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
violences raciales qui par exemple
disent que c'est une affaire souvent de
délinquance comme c'est le cas
d'ailleurs de cette affaire là certains
disent que ce l'intéressé faisait son
jogging
mais vous avez dans ceux de vous
demander à certains blancs ils vont vous
dire maintenant c'est une affaire qui
concerne la délinquance
simplement ce qu'il faut noter c'est que
depuis que d'un train est à la maison
blanche
bien évidemment un président ce n'est
pas lui qui décide en la matière mais il
ya eu plus de 1% d'augmentation de
crimes haineux de crimes raciaux
ce n'est pas la source de militants
antiracistes c'est la source du fbi
alors qu'est ce qui est en jeu il est en
jeu en particulier une libération de la
parole une libération de la parole
raciste et vous savez vous vous rappelez
peut-être de cette tribu de toni
morrison l'ancien prix nobel de
littérature qui au moment des élections
de denain train tu avais écrit cet
éditorial disant making america white
guen en plagiant le slogan de donald
trump et en disant que l'élection de
donald trump
après l'élection de barack obama premier
noir
à président des états unis avait
finalement pour beaucoup d'américains
constitué bien une manière de bien de
refuser cette société post raciale qui
est en train d'avancer aux états unis il
ya de plus en plus de couples mixtes aux
états unis est de plus en plus de
métissage donc il ya aussi une amérique
qui devient moins raciste c'est une
réalité
l'amérique de 2020 n'est plus l'amérique
des années 60 mais vous avez une
amérique qui refusent encore cela et
vous avez aussi des divisions racistes
et des divisions en matière
socioéconomique regarder pour finir la
crise ducobu 19 les afro américains ont
été beaucoup plus touchés par cette
crise est là ce qui est en cause
et bien c'est l'histoire du pays et
c'est la crise sanitaire qui touche
cette communauté merci beaucoup françois
durpaire pour votre éclairage je
rappelle que vous êtes historien et
spécialiste des états unis